hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action I'm your host Roman
Nurik and hi I'm Nick butcher
here I'm like dedi and today we're gonna
recap all the things that we talked
about on the show in 2013 it's been a
busy year we've had something like 20 or
something episodes just this year
actually probably more than 20 this is
the 23rd of this year 23rd this year
nice we've had a busy year and we're
gonna we're gonna talk about all the
different kind of highlights of the show
this year so I'm sure that you guys have
watched them all but just in case we're
going to pull out some of the highlights
that we very much enjoyed bringing to
you overview all right so without
further ado let's get started so in 2013
we had about 600,000 total views of all
of our episodes about a third of that
came from our episode on KitKat actually
about half which is great but this is
this is awesome I'm personally really
really happy that that you guys are
finding the show useful that you're
you're sharing it with your product
managers and your designers and your
developers and hopefully you know in
2014 we have even greater viewership so
thanks for watching so with that with
that kind of little bit out of the way
Mike do you want to jump in with some of
our episodes on shared inspiration and
maybe some of our rants yeah definitely
so it's we were looking back on all the
apps on the app all the episodes from
this past year and we wanted to kind of
group them in in general themes and so
I'm gonna be talking about a lot of the
different inspirational segments that we
had on the show and also some of our
rants where we just kind of go off about
how we think things should be and how
people can improve and how we can help
them so to start with that I'm gonna
look at the episode that we did about
design workflow actually we had Alex Fay
born from the Android design
on the on the show and he walked us
through some of the just the general
structure that the Android design team
here at Google uses in their design
process and this can definitely be
helpful if you're looking for a little
more structure and process to help you
improve in your design practices as we
as we can see here from these little
slide slide frames the first couple
steps are about sketches and sketching
is great because it it gives you a
chance to get your ideas out onto paper
that you can then share with with other
stakeholders without committing to
anything so paper is great
but if you don't have access or if you
prefer that you throw something on the
computer there are definitely a lot of
sketching tools available online that
you can go check out and for any of
these for any of these episodes that
we're doing feel free to go back and
watch the whole episode these are
definitely recaps so just wanting to put
that out yeah and the other things that
we have slides and not really commentary
I guess we mostly have slides available
for each of the episodes so don't feel
like you need to take screenshots or
whatever of this of this show we have
all the slides and all the videos
available at Android design and action
calm and we'll mention that link at the
very end as well yep yep yep just wanted
to get that out there so so after
sketching after getting some feedback
from your co-workers or whoever you're
working with it's great to generate
additional ideas as well and then you
can move on to wire framing which is a
little bit more formalized process where
especially for modeling interactions
between screens and user flows more
unfroze as we see in step 5 there after
after you block out the main
interactions and UI layouts with
wireframes it's a good it's a good next
natural step to move on to the more high
fidelity or full fidelity mock-ups in
Photoshop or illustrator or whatever
your your asset generation tool
of choice is and this is definitely an
iterative process if you go back and
look at the the full slides there are
about 10 of these full fidelity mock-up
slides that have all the different
iterations of the little header image or
the Google now app that the design team
went through during that process you
also want to go back and make sure that
you can clearly distinguish and spell
out the the overall flow through your
app and it helps to visualize that you
may be using an artboard in illustrator
with all the multiple screens so that
you can kind of visually show the mental
model of your information design in your
app and then red lines are it's just a
term to describe a specific metrics and
spec for for the developers who are
going to be implementing the the designs
that you've created so that's always
helpful to give them just a bunch of
assets in addition to specific metrics
to spell out you know this list item
should be 48 dips tall there's padding
around should be 16 dips etc so the next
episode that I want to recap it is say
them my overriding memory of this kind
of design process takeaway but I like
sharing the insight that often the
medium you used for kind of expressing
your ideas will dictate the kind of
feedback you get back so if you show
someone you know a very highly designed
Photoshop pixel perfect then you're
gonna get comments about the shade of
blue and drop shadow size but if you
show someone a sketch they'll go to town
on the basic idea and I thought that was
a really important thing to keep be
cognizant of when you're designing that
to keep the you know the the fidelity of
the medium in mind so it kind of just
reinforce for me like always be
sketching keep sketching as early as
possible and get loads and loads of kind
of really basic feedback before you move
on into some of these more high fidelity
names yeah definitely thanks for
pointing that out Nick and it's it's
great so I mean obviously I recently
joined the team I wasn't in almost all
of these episodes so
groaning it please feel free to jump in
as I'm recapping these with oh I'm sure
you will
one more thing that the Alex mentioned
has kind of a social engineering hack
for anytime you present your designs
is to show them using the tool you used
to create them so if your manager starts
going off on a tangent you know I wish
that was just a little bit bigger you
could just go change it right then and
he can decide that if it were better
bigger around it all rather than showing
a PDF basically show them in Illustrator
in Photoshop yeah yeah definitely
so moving on the next the next episode
I'm going to recap is the one in which
we presented the apps that were selected
to be part of the beautiful design
collection that we featured in Google
Play this is a fairly regular process
that we do here in on the team and it's
definitely worth going back to check out
those apps to understand why we really
really love them and it's one of the
great things that I think is worth
mentioning here is that these aren't
apps that were 100% hollow cookie cutter
kind of you could you've confused them
with you know Google standard apps that
come with the platform these were these
were apps that understand the holo
design language but then extend and go
beyond to to add real hero moments in
their app and to express their brand in
a in a more meaningful way yeah in this
episode we really kind of highlighted
some of those things one of the or maybe
one or two of the little details in each
app that really made it shine that
really made it stand kind of above you
know I guess the competition if you will
yeah and along the same lines the next
the next app or the next episode that we
looked at was in June there we did a bit
of a recap on the creation and the
design of the Google i/o app which is
actually a really great open source
project that we update every year
in a head of Google i/o and it we like
throwing in latest developments and new
features in the platform and it's
definitely a great reference app to go
back and look at how how a developer can
implement the kinds of design principles
that we talk about on ever design in
action
it supports it supports all the best
practices things like you know support
for different screen sizes you know use
of heavy very very heavy use of
fragments and loaders and things like
that but also it shows a lot about how
to style your action bar how to do
interesting things with the action bar
so lots of good little little kind of
tidbits in in that um ended up yep yep
definitely so definitely go back and
check that out and also check out the
open source project or the Google i/o
app and that's at code.google.com /p /
io s CH e d i remember that like the
back away if only just you know show
show a link on the screen that you could
cook yeah we could probably do that in
post in addition if you look at the high
definition video on youtube here if you
if you scan the QR code at the bottom of
the slide there that'll take you to the
Play Store where you can download and
play with the app yeah moving on yeah
so this so this was a great episode in
which Marco and omen Owen from the amber
design team came on and talked about the
sweeping redesign multi-platform
redesign of the Google Play apps so that
includes the Play Store itself and all
the different media apps that you can
use to consume content that you that you
have on Google Play Movies music books
etc so all those apps were redesigned
from the ground up with kind of the
overarching principles that they were
going for being to be responsive to have
modular elements and also to be familiar
and emotionally evocative throughout so
before if you go back and look at the
episode they show some before here here
I'm only showing the after and kind of a
nice look and feel that you guys were
used to now but if you go back and look
before they showed kind of the design
fragmentation between the web product
between the tablet and phone products
and so it was definitely a great move to
to bring everything together to brand
everything in a way that it sets an
example for for apps outside of Google
especially with the use of color and
we'll talk about that more when when we
discuss the the branding and consistency
but it's just a great example of
responsive apps where the the UI adapts
to the screen sides and the UI is is
very fluid and dynamic based on the
device you're using and it also caters
to common use cases on those devices for
example if I use my phone to download an
app that might be a totally different
experience than browsing for a movie to
watch on my tablet so that were
redesigned with that in mind especially
yeah and some of the key things that
they use they describe their use of
cards as kind of this inside-out design
approach where you know the content
really adapts to its containers and the
they talked a lot about you know use of
I guess the the differentiation of these
cards of sizes and things to better
enforce you know hierarchy and and
what's what's most important what's most
relevant to you I mean obviously a Mike
as you said the use of color is
tremendous here across all the play
properties it really helps kind of
establish a sense of place within the
entire play ecosystem you know so red if
you're in movies or blue within your
books for example yeah yeah definitely
so you always know where you are
and one thing I wanted to point out
about cards is I think this is this is
probably the most sweeping
implementation of the cards UI that
we've seen thus far I think it started
initially with Google now and now you
can see this kind of card metaphor
throughout almost every Google product
that doesn't
necessarily that you have to put cards
in your app you shouldn't try to force
it I know it's kind of become somewhat
of a visual design trend just help
understanding the purpose of the card to
kind of encapsulate a single idea or
piece of content is is a way to use that
card metaphor and your designs
responsibly yeah so let's uh let's move
on and yeah definitely feel free to
check out that episode there's a lot of
good content specifically about cards
Marco know and talk about why they use
them let's move on to favorite design
details actually one thing I want to
point out is one of the properties that
launched after that episode was Google
Play newsstand or the purple section of
play and that's actually Marco actually
discusses that in this favorite design
details episode so that's that's Marco
up here it's this guy
check out his segment of of this episode
for a discussion on Google Play
newsstand yeah yeah so Rachel bear upon
the top row there she talked about the
eight Airbnb app Roman you talked about
Foursquare Nick talked about Google
Chrome and a new kind of non-obvious
interaction patterns that are kind of
like power user features
rich Fulcher from the design team talked
about Libre out and the Libre app is
fantastic in its in its a visualization
of data how they've really made it
interactive so they track the weight you
zoom in zoom out and you can kind of
scale using gestures it's a great
experience I talked about the timely app
which is stopwatch alarm clock etc and
Nick talked about or sorry I don't talk
about the Etsy app okay quick sorry
quick quick tidbit there when when Adam
and Nick first joined the team or think
when Adam joined the team I always
confused Adam in Akeno why because they
were both taller than me well yeah I
might go on I don't mean to interrupt
you there so brutally
so and Adam recorded his bit from New
York which is why he's a little
background there looks a little bit
different but
one thing I wanted to point out is that
only a couple of these were Google Apps
and for the third-party apps that we
talked about notice that they weren't
they weren't pure Google Apps
however they were pure Android apps so
with brand consistency this is going to
be a theme in some of the other things I
talked about today you want to
communicate your brand and you want to
also stay pure to Android so pure
Android doesn't necessarily mean you
can't deviate from the design principles
like we encourage to deviate with
purpose so so the general overall theme
of this episode was that if you put the
extra effort in which a lot of the times
takes quite a bit more than just the
regular features to add hero hero
moments to add just slick animations
beautiful visual presentation and really
easy to understand and use interaction
patterns it'll just make a huge
difference overall yeah should we move
on to branding and consistency yep so
I've talked about this a couple times
already
I just wanted to illustrate this graph I
don't know who or this presentation I
don't know if this was you know I was
trying to think of a way to express it
and I got the most number of gradients
on a slide and writing well when I when
I watched this episode it I felt like
you expressed these this kind of complex
and touchy subject in the most clear to
understand way that I've heard it
expressed to date so kudos Nick so the
idea of this is your information design
your interaction design and your visual
design should kind of have a different
balance between your own brand and the
holo or Android visual style and design
language so the information designed the
the architecture of your app how
information flows throughout your app
and also how a user understands the
interactions the mental model those are
very very brandable and you should
express your information design as
creatively as you can and really let let
your simplicity in in your your branding
shine there on the other hand
interaction design you don't want to
introduce new interaction patterns for
simple navigation or you know high level
switching between views because extra
stuff that the platform already does for
you for free is just going to confuse
users or you know add steps for them to
learn how to use your app when you
should really just be finding the right
fit for existing patterns and where
needed extending those so so it's not
necessarily that you know all the
components that we provide in the
platform are the only things you should
use right but if you need a little extra
flexibility you should at least use one
of the basic components as a starting
point and then for visual design which
is what most people associate with
branding you want to strike a balance so
so they pointed out in in the episode
that the best way probably to use your
branding to highlight your ending in
your visual design is through the use of
a branded color so your it that's a
fantastic example of this is throughout
the play apps where each each play
property has its own color and that
helps between multiple apps to keep you
kind of in content in context of you
know which property you're dealing with
at the time now for most people out
there they're not going to be developing
a suite of apps like the Play Store but
at the same time you don't want your
user interface to be your brand you know
the navigation is not the brand the way
this button looks can kind of be your
brand so that's that's where the slider
is kind of halfway in the middle you
want to
take the court look and feel of the holo
design language and then extend that
don't you know replace the the right
angle triangle and a spinner drop down
with something else you know start with
that familiar place and then you can
kind of use those expected metaphors and
visual indicators throughout so that
users know exactly how a component even
if it isn't exactly as it looks they'll
know how it can be used because you're
kind of starting at the right place yeah
yeah so that's a great summary basically
you know if it's if you're gonna make
something you should make you should
make your UI elements interesting you
give them some extra you know a bit of
you know you know put in an extra punch
of branding but make sure that they're
still very very familiar because you
really want to lean on what users
already know and what users already know
are the things that are in apps like
Gmail and and Google keep and in chrome
things like the overflow things like you
know tabs and the navigations are those
things exist you know in terms of
interaction design for visual design you
really want to take that and kind of
extend holo not replace it not you know
use it wholesale but really extend it
and really kind of pump it with your own
sense with your own branding I guess
yeah definitely and then the design
principle from the Android design guide
that really is Express here is users
should have tricks that they can use
everywhere and so that's what we've been
talking about you know these little
visual indicators that users expect to
behave a certain way you know don't go
replacing that just because you think it
looks cool okay so let's let's move on
to common UX issues yeah so this was
definitely the one of our more ranty
episodes where one longer there was
there was a top 10 list we counted it
back of really common UX issues or
problems that that we on the developer
relations team see so so part of our
everyday job is to review apps
internally here at Google and also
so I work with a lot of you guys too to
help you improve your apps and these are
just things that we've seen over and
over and over and we felt like going on
a rant and spelling them out will
hopefully prevent them from spreading to
to more apps out there in the wild so I
pulled out just a couple of these for
for the full list and the full detailed
rant definitely check out the episode so
that you know what not to do
but things that I wanted to point out
where like the navigation is my brand
like I mentioned the previous in the for
the previous episode additional things
that can be pretty annoying are showing
modal loading dialogues the best way to
deal with loading in data asynchronously
over the network is to do it before you
show it to the user so wherever possible
obviously that's not possible in every
case especially for you know real-time
updates if a user wants to update a
social feed for example but when
presenting a loading indicator it's best
to do it in line either with the UI
element that's that's currently loading
or you know somewhere prominent on the
action bar for example to indicate that
that something is loading in from the
network but not necessarily you know a
pop-up dialog blocks off attraction the
worst thing about this is when when you
override the back button so that you
can't cancel the dialog until the
loading process actually completes so
that's a big no-no and you definitely
should go through your apps and it's
kind of streamline your use of loading
yeah yeah this is a this is a fun top
sign so if you're working on an app I
recommend you go back and look at these
top ten and make sure you're not
splitting foul on them yep let's let's
go on in the interest of time so I'm
gonna flip through a bunch of best
practices and actually so those episodes
you know a very inspirational we had a
bunch of rants you know a lot of that is
kind of on the lesson the education side
I guess lesson the learning about
Android more about like you know here
the types of you know things you should
be thinking about in this best practices
section I'm going to talk about some of
the episodes and very briefly some of
the episodes that we where we actually
shared some best practices some of our
kind of the specifics on you know how
you implement action bars or how you
implement navigation drawers and things
like that so the first one I want to
talk about is units of measure in this
episode which was actually coupled with
newsreader redesign which Nick will talk
about later
we talked specifically about density
independent pixels how you calculate
dips screen density grids basically
everything related to a lot of the
visual design and layout stuff that you
need to know this is kind of like a
visual design 101 for Android if you
will so if you're just getting started
definitely check out this episode where
we talk about units of measure we also
talked about looking at devices in terms
of their density independent pixel
resolution rather than pixel rather than
their pixel resolution so for example
the Nexus 7 being 960 by 600 dips and
the Nexus 5 being 640 by 360 dips and
that's a really really important point
if you're if you're getting started
doing layout for Android moving on we
had another another great episode on the
onboarding experience and a Nick
actually came up with this little the
idea of using a little snowboarder has
the icon for this episode and I got I
think I think we all got it I think
nobody talked about it but we got it the
this episode specifically talked about a
bunch of the different ways in which you
can mess up and not only messed up but
also improved the getting started
experience for your app so things like
speed bump tutorials and basically
avoiding those requiring registration
splash screens basically getting
bootstrap with the app we talked about a
lot lots of things there one of my
favorite things that we did was we
talked about some of the examples one of
my favorite apps in the space is tumblr
it actually lets you do so much without
signing in or registering or anything
you open up the app and you're
immediately given the full
app the full UI the full experience you
can even start following blogs or
following tumble blogs before you log in
so it's just a great example of that and
then we also briefly talked about
over-the-air install with the Google+
integration stuff so so it's one of my
my bare kind of subjects I kind of like
to think that there's a you know a
funnel of people trying to use your app
and every time we do one of these kind
of anti-patterns
the funnel gets smaller and you'd lose a
few users so it's really kind of like
you know interesting exercise to
critically look at your your startup
flow and see where you are potentially
gonna need some people no pressure the
next best practice thing we talked about
again in the area of visual design was
Launcher icons and this episode was
coupled with a football apps or soccer
apps as we say here in States soccer
football apps redesign so in this
section in this app sorry in this
episode we talked about some best
practices for designing Launcher icons
the sizes the the amount of spacing you
should use also the perspective you
should use and specifically the the
density of assets so this is one thing
that still keeps coming up don't forget
to include xxhdpi assets for Launcher
icons and the new world of nexus 5 and
you know larger icons on the Nexus 5
launcher it should actually be also xx
xhdpi so definitely make sure to check
out this episode if you're designing
Launcher icons moving on we we did
another episode basically doing a one on
one on the action bar I'm guessing if
you've been watching this show or this
is your first episode then thanks for
watching but if if you know if you have
learned anything about Android so far
it's probably or Android design so far
you've probably learned a little bit
about the action bar in this episode we
dove into quite a bit of detail on the
action bar the general organization you
know which things should go where
navigation on the Left
actions on the right we talked about
some guidelines for for how many actions
you should show and we also talked about
branding and this is kind of that
recurring theme that mike was talking
about earlier here's some of the ways
which you can start introducing your
branding into the app and the action bar
is a key area for that so we highlighted
some ways in which you can introduce
that you know your brand color schemes
yeah expose one of those fundamental
patterns that we say you should probably
deviate with purpose so unless you've
got a really good reason not to be using
it you probably should be using one so
if you not 100% sure about how and when
to use it then check out yep so after
the action bar we invited yen's Nagel
and rich Fulcher from the Android from
the Android design team and we talked
about rich earlier he was talking about
the the Libra app in our favorite design
details episode but Yin's and rich back
in June they talked about the navigation
drawer and this was right after Google
i/o where we announced the navigation
drawer pattern and a bunch of the
support the framework support for it but
in this episode yen's enriched douve
very deeply into the interaction design
aspects of the navigation drawer so
things like you know what should the
back button do what should be what
should you represent your information
hierarchy in the navigation drawer they
talked about things like collapsible
sections I guess you talked about hubs
navigational hubs where they're kind of
like deeper sections of your app that
are that should still be accessible
within the drawer now so they talked
about a whole bunch of details there
that was that's actually some pretty
good information on top of what's in the
design guide so if you're building a
navigation drawer definitely check out
this episode so the next episode we we
did was on collections and specifically
we showed some I guess we talked about
some best practices by way of examples
on how lots of apps right now are are
doing things right in terms of
displaying letting you search and filter
and so on collections as well as mutate
things like you know adding items to a
collection removing items from a
collection reordering taking action on
items things like that so we talked
about some things like like distillation
things like search and filter having a
right side filter drawer we talked about
responsive layout basically switching
from from lists to
grid to a staggered grid like here in an
example of pocket we talked about you
know how different apps let you act on
items using things like the contextual
action bar as well as secondary actions
and item overflows reordering items like
like using a drag grip on the side or
Google keep which is actually an
excellent example of of collections
displaying and modifying collections of
notes in this case how they actually use
drag-and-drop to let you reorder so this
episode really you know in summary it
was really just kind of a you know a
smorgasbord almost of different ways in
which apps are doing things great in
terms of collections ok moving on the
next best practice episode type thing
that we had was one on images that we
did back in October and here we talked
about the different ways in which in
which you can actually do interesting
things with images so we talked about
some best practices like how to show
text overlays when showing banner images
or or thumbnails we talked about
placeholders in this example we talked
about how Pinterest does a great job of
actually actually keying the placeholder
a color based on the image so they
actually it seems like they store
another bit almost in the database of
the key color in the image and they show
that color before the image itself loads
so it gives you a little touch of
context as to what's going to show up in
that space we also talked about the
center cropping technique which is a
great way to basically you know allow
your uisce to scale to different aspect
ratios and in the center cropping
technique you basically it's actually
very simple to use you should actually
just set the scale type to sent their
crop on an image view but in this
technique you basically chop off either
to the left and right or the top and
bottom of an image if if the aspect
ratio of the image and its target
destination don't match and we also
talked about focus things like using
blurring and din
techniques to help the user really focus
on the most important things whether it
be the text in front or you know gray
scaling and image if it's not important
things like that so overall we just
touched on a bunch of different best
practices and a couple of ideas on how
to present images so moving on we we did
another episode on best practices for
presenting maps in your app so we talked
about things like you know the different
ways in which users can interact or
should be able to interact with a map
the different ways in which you can
present and allow interaction with
markers and info windows and we spent
some time talking about the marker the
visual design of markers basically how
you can introduce branding it's
something that is you know from a shape
standpoint the shape of a marker is
generally pretty standard but how you
can actually introduce some of your
branding into that as well as how to
deal with density if you have tons and
tons of markers how can you actually
still allow the user to see the map
underneath all the markers so we talked
about that for quite a bit we talked
about fullscreen and I'll get to that in
a second we talked about an embedded map
mode which Foursquare does really well
with but we talked about about
fullscreen and actually in Android 4.4
we also talked about translucent
navigation and status bars and these
actually go hand in hand another thing
that we talked about in the Android 4.4
episode was map padding so actually in
recent versions of the map library you
can offset these controls like the zoom
control as well as the compass and my
location control you can actually offset
those and and still show the map above
and below those controls so really helps
when presenting a map and this kind of
more full screen or more immersive mode
before we move on I've been I've been
talking a lot you guys have any comments
on on maps or anything about yeah now
all right let's plow ahead we did
another episode on home screen widgets
this was back in March and in this
episode we talked about the different
types of home screen widgets things like
you know in
only widgets like your current weather
or control widgets like the power
control hybrid widgets and collection
widgets we talked about the different
kind of patterns for content to show
inside of a widget we also not pictured
in in these thumbnails here we talked
about some of the constraints like
things you just can't do with widgets
like you can't play videos and widgets
unfortunately but we did talk about some
of the things you can do like you can
actually allow for configuration of a
widget so you know one of the great
things about widgets is that they let a
user take a bit of your app and put it
on their home screen one of the most
valuable pieces of real estate on their
device and one of the best ways to have
a successful widget is to allow
customization really let the user make
it their own we also talked about some
best practices for sizing basically when
you're when you're designing the layout
for a widget we talked about some
formulas you can use to roughly figure
out how big it should be I think one of
the most important things we touched on
there which perhaps isn't quite as
well-documented as I'd like that in our
design guidelines it is the fact that
you're sharing at some real estate so
you know why your app has the full range
of expression of its brand and so forth
you when it's taking over the whole
screen when you creating a widget you
have to turn there in mind the context
it will be presented next to other
widget or app icon so I think that was a
really important section in that episode
it's how you could design your you all
widgets so that it will go along with
those other and homescreen items yeah
the specifically the visual design of
the widget it's more important to be on
that slider of branding and consistency
more important than in your app to be
closer to the Android and holo end of
that spectrum when you're designing a
widget because it's next to everything
else yeah but we love widgets you can
make an app stand out and like a really
differentiate your app from Wow
alright moving on we did a little bit of
in this section where we talked about
the i/o app in the episode where we
talked about the i/o app we also talked
about sharing and fullscreen UI's so
sharing I'm not gonna get into too much
depth here but you know we talked about
the different ways in which you can
allow users to share content things like
the the shared dialogue that's very
standard things like the share action
provider in the action
the idea here is the big message here is
that you should really allow sharing to
anything that's on the user's device not
just specifically to you know like a to
social networks or one social network
you should really kind of use whatever
the system has installed so keep that in
mind when designing sharing you eyes in
the fullscreen
I guess area we talked about system bars
things like the status bar in the
navigation bar and then we talked a
whole bunch about different interesting
ways in which you can use those bars
having like an overlaid action bar or
dimming out the status bar in a
navigation bar lots of different
interactions you can create here and
these were we talked about them in even
more depth in our in a later episode I
think it was the the KitKat episode when
we introduced immersive mode in KitKat
we talked about some of the even newer
ways you can do really really fullscreen
really immersive you eyes so if you're
building a full-screen experience like a
video player or a full-screen game or a
book reader or even a photo gallery
definitely make sure to check out this
episode from June 4th as well as the
KitKat episode which was very reason
alright moving on I think I think we're
at the yeah this is the last this is my
last line here the last kind of best
practice and best practice type episode
that we had was about design tools so in
this episode we talked a lot about the
different tools that the users that the
designers on the Android team use things
like obviously illustrator fireworks
Photoshop but we also talked about some
of the some of the interaction I get
some of the wire framing tools that you
have available to you as an Android
designer things like Omni graph will
fluid UI proto do we kind of did a
compare and contrast sort of of those
different interaction design tools and
they're probably countless more today
than they were back when we did this
episode but if you're looking for kind
of a getting started guide on which
tools you should get started with
definitely this is a good episode one
last thing is we briefly talked about
the
the Android design preview tool which
lets you mirror something from your
computer from like a photoshop window to
your device you can see it live and we
talked about things like the Android
asset studio and holo colors generator
an action bar style generator that let
you basically create all the assets you
need for the basics of your Android app
things like the action bar background
and things like that
tolling is always an emotive subject I
mean people feel passionate about their
tools and it's interesting some of the
feedback we've got episode and some new
tools of emerged I think for me sketch
is one of the tools which is on my list
of tools to check out a lot of people
are saying that have a lot of success
using that but kind of a vector-based
design mm-hmm for sure okay and I think
that about covers it for the best
practices section Nick do you want to
talk about all the redesigns and
mock-ups we did in 2013 yeah absolutely
so redesigns are kind of very much in
the kind of DNA at the Android design in
action show it's none of the in action
part where we like to kind of show
rather than just talk about things and
so while they take a lot of time and we
haven't been able to do quite as many as
password like it's been some really
really fun shows where we've managed to
either reimagine certain apps out there
or and take a look at like and a
hypothetical app what it might look like
so going to take a few from some of our
February designs so all the way back in
January the first you know meat flavor
your favorite meat flavored Reader app
the first time we introduced it this was
an episode where we introduced this idea
of iterative design and so it was really
really fun to take an application which
you had like zero styling applied to it
or at all just had some raw content in
there and walk you through the steps
that we were then you know we would do
to improve things like you know applying
themes and applying the metrics and the
under design pie and take a look at
typography and literally build it up
step by step and as you can see if Roman
pans around here to go from sewing which
looks completely bare you know doesn't
look an Android app not exactly sure how
to use it to you know swimming which
looks really attractive
and communicates its information IRR key
and really sells the content so if you
haven't checked this out that's probably
my all-time favorite episode of Android
design
and really in like breaks down how we go
about improving your application yeah
and the one thing we try to do
throughout is talk about some of the
developer features that we use so in the
bottom-right of a lot of the slides
there's a little kind of for developers
note so keep that in mind if your
developer yeah absolutely
next episode we don't want to talk about
is in February we took a look at
football not soccer football apps if
they're the application logical addict's
and we reimagined what it could look
like by applying some more of the
Android design guidelines so we did a
lot of things we know we do like kind of
applying more Android II kind of flatter
look and feel and using action bars and
and so forth which I think instantly you
know it made it look more like an
Android app to me and made it
communicate its purpose its interaction
patterns much clearer for me and after
the redesign some of that and but the
two two things I wanted to mostly pull
out here and they're kind of slightly
larger pitches are and I really enjoyed
the little with this redesign taking a
look at the navigation and the way the
major navigation was organized because
they were pretty using a draw which kind
of seemed to you know there wasn't too
many major sections to this application
and so by kind of flattening down there
the current navigation hierarchy we were
able to move it over to you using a tab
based interface with lesser use punch
and tucks away under the overflow like
settings and and that instantly was much
clearer I think you know if you can use
a tab based navigation which immediately
communicates the gasps purpose to user
or a using here or so using the action
bar spinner so not tabs then I thought
this was a great you know a great
stepping back exercise and not using a
drawer just because it's attractable in
new hotness but actually thinking of the
simplest way to communicate a section
yeah that was really fun
yeah one of my favorite parts of this we
also did a bit with the color scheme you
know we talk a lot about single accent
colors like a lot of the play properties
use a single accent color in this case
we actually in the redesign we decided
to use two accent colors this kind of is
I guess D saturated dark brown and a
almost like a forest green so you know
don't feel like you should be limited to
a single accent color you know if it
makes sense for your app to use to
accent colors absolutely feel free to do
that here's just one example of how we
did that yeah moving on so in March we
took a look at and how you might create
a hypothetical newsreader so we've built
on top of this kind of XYZ this meaty
reader and explore some interesting ways
in which you can you know do news
reading experiences so some fun stuff
explorations in there things like using
multi multi-finger gestures in order to
kind of keep more content leading to
connect you know the lighter-weight
process and so forth I was really
interested in the use of search to
flatten the hierarchy of what I was
really interesting a lot of applications
struggle with how you communicate a
really really complicated hierarchy of
topics and so forth and using search and
kind of customization to flatten and and
navigate that I thought was a fun
approach to it that's very good one a
brief thing I want to mention is this
markup was done before we had the
official navigation drawer pattern so
some of the markups some of the designs
you see here are actually not quite up
to date in terms of how you should use
the navigation drawer oh yeah all those
in content or stuff oh well but lastly I
think they're kind of the bottom right
image slider Bechet I very much enjoyed
and the discussion we had around
focusing on content because kind these
news weekend actually it's all about
content right it's all about presenting
and getting users to story they want to
read and the little interface design
things that you can do to make that
reading experience the reason that
they're more pleasant can really help so
we played with some ideas around hiding
the action bar about when to surface new
content about going into this kind of
lights-out mode as we call it where you
and you dim any other distractions in
the UI and I thought that was really fun
to kind of like really really have a
laser focused application and that was
good yep next up was
sowed in March where we took a look at
what a hypothetical podcast creator app
might look like so this was an app where
we kind of mocked up and design but
stepping back from that I really enjoyed
that we started from kind of a stage
before the mock-ups and redesigns if you
will we started from the information
hierarchy and really kinda like took
some time to think about what it was
that was trying to achieve and how that
would influence us to the screen design
later on so I really enjoyed that we
kept an information model and in fact we
use the labels throughout the design to
show which screens were ticking off
certain use cases we were trying to try
to cover off so that was a plan for so
which I'm helping I was there for but I
didn't enjoy your watching him moving on
yeah moving on in July we took a look at
an application called cenotes and this
is actually from GDG Oslo I believe we
we did kind of a live app clinic I guess
with with the creators of the SAP and
then they were like hey can you show us
some ideas and show some mock-ups of
what you how you would design this so we
went ahead and did that yeah that was a
fun one so I think there was some really
nice work done to better express the
kind of information hierarchy seemed in
general reorganization there as well as
I'm moving some of the kind of interface
patterns like the action bar the
navigation draw a bit closer to the you
know the platform pattern in order to
kind of make them feel more intuitive so
that users kind of kind of pick up the
application and know how to navigate
around which I thought was really nice
but the one thing I wanted to highlight
a misapplication and we touched on it
recent edge is a couple seconds minutes
ago talking about information
collections with the use of the
right-side trough the sorting option so
I very much enjoyed this I think this is
a great way to kind of bundle up and
different your sorting options and it
can feel like a lighter weight action
rather than taking users off to a second
screen or a dialog perhaps so letting
them kind of set their sorting options
and and better yet if you can have them
say updating the background so you can
see as I move that slide I left all
right
if I could see the number of results
like changing the background I think
it's a really really nice way to make it
feel like I'm you know directly working
on this data rather than it's a slow
Machinery process that I'm pulling a
lever and that's causing a process that
you've got something out so I thought
that was a really really nice touch in
that episode yep moving on so any
designs this here yeah it's fun okay
with you in July we took a look at a
hypothetical cricket app so this is off
the back of a reto Meier dan excellent
episode the app clinic talking to power
his ideal sports app and how you would
build it and but we then picked up the
ball off the pin and then talk about how
we can like her around styling that and
much in the vein of the iterative design
process we took this step and this
application step by step so we looked at
you know the information density and the
typography and the visual theming and so
on and built it up step by steps talking
through why we were making the changes
and how you change them and then we kind
of went one step further as well and
show an example of how you might read a
line such as designed to communicate all
of these design decisions from a
designer to a developer so that knobs
opposing yep very fun episode and I
think that was it for the redesigns that
year right
yeah we ran out seemed in July it seems
yeah they took quite a bit of time right
there they're pretty time-consuming they
are very fun but very time-consuming all
right yeah so the end more section we
had a couple of episodes that didn't
really fall into any of those three
themes that we didn't want to talk about
Nick they want to jump into those yeah
absolutely so in May just after the
conference itself and we took some time
to talk about what happened at Google
i/o and in particular to highlight some
of the sessions that will be most
relevant to designers working on Android
applications so I put out a few slides
here so three of my favorite and talks
front from Google i/o 2013 where this
topper of slides here so that's talking
about Android design principles the
second one was talking about
Alex Pabu again friend of the show
Tuesday talking about cognitive science
just a fascinating talk and really kind
of one of those talks that gets in your
head and sticks with you and you kind of
keep thinking about it as you go as
you're working on your design and the
third one I've highlighted there is
reaching the ends again and who did
similar as we were just talking about in
the podcast creation they kind of focus
on the process about going back to first
principles and thinking about your
information model and how you flesh it
out and kind of take the process of
taking that and turning it into use
cases and then it's kind of like and
screen design and so forth so those are
some of my favorite talks and I also
talked a highlight that we had a
wonderful session called a kind of
Android design in action life and where
we have some very very kind of amazing
TAS or helpers from from the Android
design in action community so shout out
to you guys you are awesome who came
along and helped us to run a session
talking about the kind of things we
talked about the show about how to you
know take an idea and especially out
internet fiction model and then sketch
get sketch to create interesting apps
and that was just phenomenal we weren't
quite sure how I was going to work that
I was blown away with the passion and
the kind of the ideas that people
brought to that session so that was
really a very fun firstly not a recorded
show IO but maybe we can do it again one
day
yeah for sure we definitely if they're
recording up so they record a session
like that and we do have all the
materials online so if you actually want
to run through the same I guess problem
that we ran through the same I guess
question the same task we ran through
that material is all available online
a lot I pulled out maybe it's more of a
plug because it was a moaning session
where we took off our designer hats and
put on our developer hats and instead
talks about how and developers in the
audience can actually go about creating
all these things so rather than the kind
of principles and the visual design but
how you actually go about implementing
them so one more for the developer
audience okay and and lastly I think is
Roman alluded to somehow our breakout
success of the Year by viewcount at
least and in October we we did a show
recap some of the more
interesting things in KitKat for design
audience so some of the things I've
taught that I've highlighted here on
this slide talking about their changes
to have the different immersive or
fullscreen modes that you can use
including the translucent bar mode so
where you can actually draw behind some
of the system chrome we talked about the
changes in branding and about how KitKat
has tried to reduce the kind of high
contrast that bringing attention to kind
of you know less important things like
touch feedback instead there's trying to
make those more subtle allowing your
your room more space to kind of like use
color for expressing things which are
important or require emphasis rather
than for kind of like these highly kind
of like jarring you know responses to
their gestures and so on head touches
and so and so we also covered some of
the newer documented patterns so these
are gesture SRI which have been codified
I guess in the design guidelines for
things like the double touch drag which
you'll find it's great gesture for like
single helix zooming and you'll find it
in things like Chrome and maps and so
forth so that's a great pattern to chess
just like that as well as not really a
design feature but saying it's really
work being aware of it's an the new
ability kick hat to record to ground
videos of them here or from the device
so this is a great way for you know if
you're going to pro can get your
developer to prototype something and
record a video of it and you can like
pass it around to get feedback from
people is a very handy tool to have in
your toolbox yep for sure
so that's it for Android design in
action in 2013 as you can see we had
quite a long year 23 episodes was it you
know we talked a lot about some
inspirational things we we went on quite
a few long rants especially in that
common UX issues episode we did a bunch
of redesigns and mock-ups and of course
we we shared some best practices some of
the specifics on how to use an action
bar navigation drawer and so on so she's
stepping back and looking at the kind of
things we did so do let us know in the
comments or on Google+ or Twitter or
whatever
which kind of aspects you enjoy or you
enjoy a balance or what you want to see
more off in the future yeah yeah and if
there's something that we haven't done
on the show before that you think would
be cool definitely let us know in the
comments as well yeah that we have we
have a bunch of ideas but we need we
need even more ideas so definitely let
us know
so with that see you in 2014
got 2014 sounds like such a such a weird
thing but it's like it's tomorrow it's
not only tomorrow's just a few days we
chorist the future is now
alright with that as always I'm your
host Roman Nurik and buy from a Nick
butcher I'm like Getty so yeah see you
guys in 2014